- Doesn't Obama know he won't
be able to get anything done
in his last two years?
(laughs)
He doesn't give a (beep)!
(audience laughs)
Oh, no! (laughs)
Yes, look!
No wonder he's throwing
Mars at us, Vic!
(beep) Why not
Jupiter, Obama, right?
(audience laughs)
Jupiter's got more moons, man!
Yes!
(audience laughs)
- When you meet people
in D.C., politicians,
and they put one face
out to the public,
and then behind the scenes,
they're devious
lunatics, you know?
And they're head cases, and
they're broken, garbage people.
(laughter)
- In all your interviews
with Obama, okay,
did you ever have a
moment where you thought,
"This guy's an ass (beep)"?
(laughter)
- [Person] Keep it 100.
(speech drowned out by laughter)
- Hey, America,
Larry Wilmore here.
If you like The Nightly
Show on Comedy Central,
like us on Facebook too!
Just don't poke me.
I do not like being poked.
You can Candy Crush me.